George Santos known to some as Anthony
devolder known to some as kitara his
drag queen Persona George Anthony Katara
Santos de volder you know who I'm
talking about right the guy who lies he
now is saying the five hundred thousand
dollar loan I claimed I gave my campaign
it wasn't really from me now he might
think this is going to explain problems
that he's having the problem is where
did he get the 500 Grand the problem is
it actually raises a new question of did
he lie on the financial disclosures
claiming it was his money when it really
came from someone else particularly in
the context of the reality that there
are limits to how much people can
contribute to the campaigns of others he
may have admitted to a crime maybe not
but he's almost certainly lying